summarize my day summarize my week what are my calendar events like that phrase exactly and
that is a better poc if you can pwn that versus the user saying hello hi whatever that's such a
that is such a good call out rezo that is a really good comment
best method of hacking when you can just you know critical thing
all right hackers look we got a lot i don't know if you guys know this but there's a lot more to
ctpb than just the podcast okay i'm just going to list a couple things you guys might be interested
in real quick okay we got the discord that's where a lot of awesome conversations are happening this
cool research channel in particular is amazing on the discord we've got the full-time hunter's guild
for those of you making over 100k a year in bug bounty if you're looking to be around other elite
hackers that's the place to do it we've got the critical thinkers tier on the discord that's where
we uh that's like our inner circle that's where we share all of our scripts do exclusive amas master
classes that sort of thing and we've got the research lab over at lab.ctbb.show where if you've
got a piece of research you'd like to submit you can submit it there and we may take it hosted on the
blog and cover it on the pod for you um also underappreciated but we also have the swag store guys so
hit the swag link over at ctbb.show and you guys can buy some cool t-shirts uh with uh critical thinking
know slogan and stuff like that on it all right um with that let's go back to the show check out some
of those things all right we're gonna go back to the show but check out those things for me all right
let's go all right sup hackers welcome to the this week in bug bounty segment we got a couple of
news items that did not make it into the episode that i wanted to make sure got in front of you guys
the first one warms the heart it is our boy ronnie carta lupin was featured in a hacker one blog
by maggie miller um so definitely go check this out if you want to hear more about ronnie's story
if you guys have been listening to the pod you probably know a good amount about running story but
deppy his um supply chain product is amazing one of the best uh supply chain products out there
really doing a lot of uh unique research in that arena as well um so if you want to learn more you
can check out the link we'll we'll put it in the description it's on the hacker one blog under ronnie
card bug bounty next is uh kaido actually released a new plugin called auth swap this is by bevix um and
this one i just wanted to show you guys this for those of you that are um watching on youtube it's
just a really awesome plugin that allows you to swap your session super easily so you define these
user profiles you say okay set this cookie for this user set this cookie for that user right and then
um it just puts these buttons in your replay where you've got user a user b and you can just press
them and it applies that transformation to your open replay request right so it makes it really easy
for you to swap sessions and go after those off vulnerabilities which are just everywhere um we're
releasing a lot of stuff like this with kaido right now we've got like i know some some people have
been doing authify there's authorized there's auth matrix there's auth swap so um there's a lot of
auth based plug-in for whatever you are going after in kaido and we've also got some shift stuff
coming there too so be on the lookout there but this is a very manual approach right
and i know that aligns with some of the bug bounty hunters that really like to do everything themselves
to ensure full coverage so check out auth swap if you're interested in that okay last is something
a little interesting i wanted to tell you guys about takumi okay takumi is uh gmo securities uh flat
securities um continuous source code review ai okay so there are a lot of people building ai products right now
but i know i know i know the guys that are building this and i know that takumi is amazing okay
the way that it's implemented it does an excellent job and it's very affordable if you go to the website
flat.tech slash takumi t-a-k-u-m-i um then you can check it out it's very affordable it's free
for open source products right zero yen per month and uh the basic plan is uh seven monen which is
70 000 uh yen which is about 450 usd um and this contains i think what it says here is that it
contains about one month's worth of credits where you can do source code review okay um using the ai
very good stuff very good results out of here from what i've seen under the hood wanted to make you
guys aware of that this is like really the s tier stuff in japan so if you're wanting to try to understand
you know take advantage of what um what companies are ahead in other markets then you should definitely
check out takumi because they are ahead in my opinion um all right that's all i had for this week
let's get back to the show all right man i feel like i gotta be real with the audience on this one
like right before i'm like squeezing this little stress ball thing so hard right now because right
before we got on the air i have been fighting with a css issue in this plugin that i'm coding
for like an hour an hour and a half and i just it's totally not even worth your time
i'm about to lose it dude css i i freaking love css but i hate css dude i really do
um why is this so complicated it feels like it's like um a stack of layered complexity on top of a
million other things and i know you specifically are complaining about tailwinds as like another
you know i love i love the kind of team i love them i love them to death but they they're on this whole
tailwind kick and i just can't get behind it and i just don't like the added complexity of like
classes and oh did it did it like generate the correct class i don't know there's just there's
all sorts of stuff with it but has jan given you his bull case for it he has he has and he's right of
course you know but but for me like i i you know i'm just a simple hacker you know man i'm not a dev
you know i i just all i want to do is just like pop open dev panels tweak it to how i want it to look
copy the css put it in there you know like put it in inline screen you know like whatever yeah but um
yeah okay all right just breathing just breathing through this um so what you're what you're actually
saying for the listener is if they hear any rage behind your voice about anything it's not intended at
the content it's just you've got this it's ian's fault is what it is yeah it's a fault yeah no um
uh all right dude let's get to it um well actually okay before we jump into the defcon fun
uh i do want to talk to the listeners about a new um research piece that popped up through the lab so let
me go ahead and get that up i thought i had it up before but i don't um but this is just a cool once
again we are trying to incentivize people with uh the research lab to do little micro blogs with cool
you know two paragraph you know this one's a little longer but the tldr is pretty short like hey this is
what i found this is how it worked maybe you can use this little gadget right i just think that's so
valuable um super valuable yeah and so um this one was awesome uh this one was actually relating to
unicode surrogates uh and how i didn't really think about how they would affect um the specific databases
uh and the them being converted by unicode normalization or not knowing how to represent
these things into the question mark character right um so here's the here's the write-up right here
and the tldr of it is you know there are some scenarios in which these unicode surrogates in
particular you know other unicodes may not but these surrogates that are often used in emojis
um will get normalized into a question mark character and the question mark character obviously we know
you know i thought about in the context of urls okay you know it's going to truncate the url whatever
that's basically like two separate conversions like one thing is falling back into a question mark like
character and then it's being translated to the question mark later uh i'm i'm not sure that could
that's a great point it could be like um that conversion between unicode into the unicode question
mark and then the unicode question mark into the into the actual normal question that's how i understood
yeah yeah it certainly could be but however it worked out it panned out um this character uh and
uh other unicode characters this specifically one is um unicode code point dc2a was being converted
into a question mark and that question mark was then being converted into a wild card character in
solar or elastic search he's not sure which one uh because of the of the situation but he he looked
into it and found two databases that use it as a wild card character um so that is clutch uh and i totally
didn't think about it in like the the sql or like the database perspective right um versus like the url
uh query parameter perspective yeah so is this basically like when you're fuzzing like when you're
looking for interesting things and you're looking for characters that might bypass specific um like
parsing or things like that uh people just need to be aware of potentially testing for surrogate pairs yeah
exactly and and seeing if those are normalizing into question marks and whether those question marks the
big thing for me is that oh of course those question marks can can be converted into you know wild
card characters that was that was the big thing because i knew you know i know unicode normalization
sometimes through the pipes or whatever ends up with a with a question mark at some point um but
specifically this surrogate uh is it does this and then results in a question mark which can be uh
used as a wild card in a database wasn't something i'd really really thought through yeah i feel like
it always get normalized to the question mark inside the little square icon so i bet then that's getting
converted to a real question mark which is being interpreted as the wild card and if it even if it
wasn't in his scenario i'm sure that does exist that scenario does exist so yeah um all right dude so
for this episode we kind of went back through a bunch of different defcon videos that that finally
got posted and we finally got around to actually uh watching them and tried to pull out some juicy
goodness for you guys the listener um i've got let's see one two three four five five talks that i can
talk about uh i don't know how many you grabbed but um i've got one two three four five but mine's more
like three and then like two that are so deeply technical on things that i'm not an expert in but
i still pulled out some like things that i thought were worth mentioning yeah dude and then you've got
like some mega list over here as well oh i i just put the whole list of the bug bounty village talks in
case we wanted to like uh comment on those i mean obviously so many people that we know well and so
i didn't know if there were any of these that you had heard good things about or had heard mentioned
so yeah let's put the full list in here dude i was i was a little salty to not be able to make it
to a lot of the talks this year like i had to like in and out defcon this year um and do you know if
those were recorded or if they'll be put up anywhere i feel like i heard they're not or something sort of
recorded i think uh so i'm i messaged harley and i'm trying to get like you know i'm trying to see if
he'll just give me the recording so that i can you know condense some of the information down but um
yeah i think they'll be up eventually i think okay yeah um but let's dive into it um the first one that
i okay well first we can't talk about defcon talks without mentioning the http 1.1 must die uh from
james kettle and the port swigger research team we're not going to talk about that because we did a whole
episode on that already so go listen to that episode if you um if you haven't already uh the one
that i wanted to start off with is actually prompt scan exploit ai's journey through zero days
uh by the expo team and this one was interesting because they didn't actually get to give the talk
at defcon they had to uh record it afterwards and post it on the website um so this video i think
only has like a thousand something views very very few people really bleeding it i haven't seen it i
need to go watch it it's it's it's good man there's a lot of good content in there so um let me let me
pick out a couple of the things you should definitely go watch it yourself but um let me pick out a
couple of the the key points for me um so the first one is they kind of you know about halfway through
the talk you know they cover all like the um how expo works and like uh the output things that they do
the blog posts off of um they covered those but then later on they covered the challenges that they
faced while building expo that uh bug bounty hunters should be aware of if they're building their own
ai systems which i happen to be doing right now uh you know so i was like oh this is very interesting
but the first challenge that they came up against was saying that they noted was ai costs uh are high
versus traditional costs uh but they they really did map this out and we've seen this time and time again
uh ai costs are going to continue to drop we saw 76 cut um uh what is this between uh gemini pro 1.5 at
launch and uh gemini 1.5 pro in 2024 um and have to of 2024 so and we're going to see and we saw another
86 drop um after that so like the costs are just continuing to just tank for these things um and so
even if like let's say i do think a lot of people um might be skeptical about that there are many people
i know which i don't necessarily agree with that think that the bubble's gonna pop and that this is
basically companies burn burning subsidization investor funds right like yeah they're just trying to
mass adopt users but i think that what's really crazy and really cool is that so many of these
models are like they get distilled they get reused they get fine-tuned they like it seems like even
when the like let's say even if the latest and greatest models went up in price which i don't
actually know that i believe they will the previous models which are just still insanely good like
gemini 2.0 flash and like even even this it's like uh in the screenshot it's 1.5 right they're
already at 2.5 and i think 3 just recently came out or is at least in testing already on like some of the
battle arena sites and so i think like um even if price the prices don't like stay low forever these
older models are still really capable for things like this yeah yeah so essentially their takeaway
here was like don't worry about cost of ai right now exactly you know just build it and then eventually
you know the older models are going to be so cheap it's like who gives a lily you know um and i i
do agree with that and i also think uh models that are open source are also getting pretty good um and so
then you kind of just have to pay for energy which is not which which by the way is not uh inconsequential
you know like like it does cost money real money guys uh your energy bill will feel it if you're
running like ai stuff constantly um i once was like calculating out oh you know i got this big server
from the store or you know and i was like i'm gonna run it in my basement and kill my vps costs and i'm
like calculating out i'm like oh this is gonna cost me like 15 a month in electricity i should just spin
up a vps you know exactly exactly so yeah there are some gotchas there um okay challenge three
i'm skipping over a couple too many assets right they were saying okay this is um
a problem we've got too many urls too many things to scan so they did a couple things one they they
used uh they parsed the scope ezps we're not going to talk about that i'm going to talk about the two
other things scoring and deduplication okay scoring and deduplication scoring is uh essentially the way
they approached identifying which targets are interesting they created like this massive 80
it looked like 80 or so attribute list for these targets it says does it have graphql does it have
forms does it have an api does it have a password reset you know the those sort of things yes or no
and then it asked the ai those questions and rated each one of the the hosts right and then it would
focus on the host that has the highest scoring rating um like it's almost like a likelihood to be
vulnerable type scoring yeah like if it's a play like if it's a plain hello world page with nothing
on it it would just rank it a zero because there's no functionality there right yeah yeah exactly and
and um and so and you know obviously there are situations where oh it's like you know there's some
hidden path or whatever um but i mean this is this is a good start and i think that cut
down about 45 of their targets you know they're able to focus more on the top you know 45 well the
reason why i love this i've obviously talked to a lot of hackbot companies the vast majority are not
approaching hackbot in this way like um the thing that i love the expo has done all the way since the
beginning relative to other hackbot companies is like it felt like they wanted to be a full black box like
here you're given this bug bounty program now go like attack it yeah um i the majority of other
companies they just take input as url and so like they're not even worried about the problem of like
which domain do i look at so i i think it's just kind of cool that they even um wanted to solve this
problem in the first place totally like that it was a part of their desire was to actually decide
which subdomains to look at it's a part of the bug bounty design man you know it it really is you
know these guys are bringing a bunch of bug bounty automation experience into this whole thing uh which is
invaluable text though i'm sure um so the next one was deduplication i think this one was interesting
because we've i've seen a bunch of people try to address this problem right we've seen the top
hackers you know in the automation world try to address this sometimes you do visual distance based
off of screenshots sometimes you do like dom hashing you part you you know parse the dom and you try to
like use sim hash and like uh you know figure out the dynamic content exactly yeah and you try to figure
out what's dynamic what's not um the one that they mentioned here that was very interesting was they
use text content uh and embeddings yeah and really and then creating ai exactly exactly so i'm like okay you
know this is a very interesting thing here like um we're not necessarily uh you know going to be using
ai here but we are doing this embedding process right you know or like we're not going to be using
lms like hey you know take this and like tell me what it is you know um but instead you are using some
of the core technology behind it that allows you to take meaning and assign it to like a vector you know
a a um a series of numbers and then um you know use that to identify okay you know are these you know
what is the cosine difference between this one and this one and say okay wow these are really similar
like we should these are probably dupes right so so then you dedupe uh much more efficiently there
based off of meaning you know versus off of like whatever visual display or or um uh you know whatever
hashing the techniques we have so i just thought that was a really unique um way of solving that
problem it's super cool and i think like immediately my brain jumps to i want to see it in visual space
i want to see a three-dimensional like node graph of oh which i mean i guess they actually do have that
for image based already don't they but anyways yeah for vector base i feel like it's like actually
the representation of really what you're what the vectors are you know of course you're condensing
down some sort of like one million dimension space down to like 3d but it would be cool to see like
little clusters of domains based on that dude that would be sick totally sick i totally that was not
where my brain went at all my brain was like really my brain was like great deduplication well yeah well
anytime i think of vector space that's how i visualize it it's just like a big 3d space and you know by
vectorizing you're taking that content and you're putting it at a single point and so whenever you say
cosine similarity distance i think oh those points are really close in that 3d space and so now what what do i want to see for um
um uniqueness for like uh anomalies is like what's not close to the other ones so i imagine if you mapped
it onto 3d space you would see a whole bunch of domains that are all together and then you would
see some like that are like kind of off on their own and it'd be cool to be able to just click those
to go to them yeah that would be cool that'd be super cool yeah yeah um so yeah i thought that was
really unique um the the next challenge that they they represented was boundaries you know setting
setting scope staying in scope that sort of thing and they one of the ways that they did this was they
um implemented dynamic dns uh for this whole thing so they're just not resolving some of the domains
that are not in in their scope and i think that that is a good solution to solve it at the dns level
um you know some of the llm stuff can break so many sides though yeah yeah it could but uh i think you
can also do some contextual awareness on it right like uh let's say it's loading a third-party script
or whatever um and that third-party script you know you need to respond with like you know you
sandbag it to your server and respond it with like a 200 and an mtjs file or something like that you know
um i i feel like it's better just to like not let it modify requests to sites that aren't in scope
just let it load or maybe like let it load stuff right but like don't let it target it focus exactly
don't let it send requests to that yeah yeah i thought that was interesting and then um oh uh so
challenge number seven number eight was essentially this whole concept of how do we get the most out of
the models and what they were saying is they actually saw a really big increase in efficacy when
switching back and forth between different models essentially like every rotation of the agent
flip a coin pick a model you know like and and just you know distribute it right you know going for
like this uh statistical approach because what will happen is one model will get stuck
right and it'll get stuck and it'll rotate it'll rotate it'll rotate but you know somewhere in that
rotation a different model's getting added in to the mix and then that model will bring its own
perspective and then that'll get handed back to the other model and that's the breakthrough needed to
like continue going further right so just like by subbing in and out different models
you get differences in approach and um and they said that that increased efficacy a lot which i was
kind of surprised because i feel like it'd be kind of a scattered brains like oh let me try this oh let
me try this no i'm gonna go this way but really it seemed to to work well from what they said yeah i
remember i think we covered that on like a podcast episode a little bit ago when they kind of first
published that paper or maybe when we were talking to diego we mentioned that but yeah i agree i i think that
models today all feel so similar they all are like as long as you're getting ones in the same class right like if you're
comparing gpt5 to gemini 25 pro to claude 4 or whatever it feels like they're all like kind of the same
intelligence uh but yeah i mean i guess that the internal structures are like very different and so
you're gonna get like different approaches different attempts yeah yeah and then the last thing that they
mentioned was they're diminishing returns on number of rotations per vulnerability type um so you know
what they're saying is okay you know it typically only on average it's only gonna take me you know
eight times or whatever to get this xss right and then it produces diminishing returns right so like
for per vulnerability class understand where the optimal point of roi is on number of rotations uh versus output of
valid vulnerabilities and then limit your agent to that to maximize like your your output of
vulnerabilities because instead you can allocate those computing resources to another endpoint which
is going to produce more vulnerabilities um yeah it's so cool that you can basically gamify anything
these days like you can create an evaluation and so i'm sure that's what they did right they were like
oh let's create an evaluation and figure out if it hasn't figured out by four steps it's never going to
figure it out yeah so just don't waste any cycles after that and just stop right at four steps you know yeah
yeah pretty solid so overall a really good talk definitely underrated uh i'm going to link it in
the description you guys should check it out um anybody who's even remotely thinking about using
ai or integrating ai or creating an ai hacking product should check that out because there's a lot
of lessons learned and they're sharing very freely um so all right um you want to take the next one
yes and you had a different opinion on this one so i think it's going to be kind of exciting for us to
talk about it yeah i even went back and like parsed through it before we recorded it and i still
i think you're wrong so here we'll talk about it all right we'll debate it so it's called breaking into
thousands of cloud-based vpns with one bug and this is a talk by david cash and rich warren i'm sure these
guys are legends um outside of the bug bounty industry i'm sure they're like amazing hackers
i think that they're from the uk but anyways they basically found a bunch of bugs in zscaler and netscope
i think presumably it seemed like it was because they they run into them so often on their pen tests
and so they wanted to kind of like you know be able to really compromise them um i personally um
thought that one of the coolest things they did and in their slide deck like every few slides once
they found vulnerabilities they would like check it off they basically created a wish list of bugs
and in general i think that like achievement or like um you know a task-based hacking is really
valuable we've talked about a little bit on the pod i think you specifically do this kind of a lot
right when you're going to love hacking it's like oh i want rc on this feature or i want to be
able to like listen to anybody's conversation in this device right it's like you set up a goal and
then you go and get it and usually somehow it's just like the stars aligned to make it possible it's
probably because everything is vulnerable if you work hard enough yeah um but i think that's just really
cool um as like a takeaway for buck hunters as like a wish list um i did think that it was neat they
had a multiple items on their wish list right like i feel like as hackers sometimes we go to events
saying like oh rc and this thing is just like one having the wish list is pretty neat because you can
probably pivot between them yeah i i think there's a you know point of diminishing returns with that as
well right like you're like sure you need to stay focused but maybe you know be open to the
possibilities of how the system is implemented you know where the vulnerabilities might be um but i
definitely like that concept as well and i think it's especially applicable to appliances and iot devices
or whatever right because um you know oftentimes there are just very specific things you want to do like
point to own all about shelling the device right um and so you've got a very narrow focus there and it
makes it a lot more intense for sure yeah so i personally was surprised by how much appsec there
was in this you may you may disagree but i mean there was like so many slides they had that were basically
like here's the http request and here's the http response and like kind of we're breaking it down
which i was delightfully pleased by um because they were often looking at like um you know the desktop
installs of these apps um but anyways they uh the one thing that i thought was like a really great
takeaway was they found pre-auth configs for both zscaler and netscope and i'm pretty sure that still
existed today that wasn't like some vulnerability i think that what was in there was a little bit too
much data whenever i was app omni and did sas security i also found this on workday for example
a lot of sas based uh apps that are like multi-tenant will for some reason have like some sort of like
externally available config it'll usually include things like the org name or some other stuff and
you can um you can like garner a little bit of information about it sometimes it's not it's usually
not a vulnerability but it gives you a lot of information about the target in this case a couple
of them were actually vulnerabilities but i thought that it was um i thought that it was pretty neat
um you can see uh actually well i won't share but for the audience there's a um there's an
endpoint for netscope that's like git slash mobile slash user slash pack um and then question mark org key
and so as long as you have the org key uh which is able to be found in a couple different ways they
talk about in the talk so you should go watch that but you can like return a bunch of information about
that org and it very often included sensitive things like routes uh internal host external host
um and in some cases they would even include keys and stuff but um i thought that that was uh one
thing is neat i i like meta concepts and i think in sas having like a pre-auth config as like a meta concept to
know to look for or to like google force like if you're trying to target a specific you know desktop
thing or sas thing and you're like hey what's the pre-auth config url for this app right and then that
gives you more information about it and sometimes might be leaking things that shouldn't dude those
those meta ideas are just going to become more and more and more valuable though as you know as well
as we move into a bunch of ai stuff supplemented hacking over the next couple of years because those
meta concepts are going to be able to be pulled out and applied specifically um yeah totally uh and and
i think i've definitely seen this as well you know with these appliances you've got to look for
i mean it's just this is kind of what it boiled down to you know i kind of covered this in a talk a
while back when i was talking about my approach to hacking grafana um back in like 2020 but essentially
it's like you just got to look at the routes and you know look at the routes look at the unauthenticated
routes and then that is your what you can work with you know yeah you've got you've got if you
want an unauthenticated bug you've got two options you bypass auth or you work with the unauthenticated
routes you know like and so uh you know you just kind of break it down into the steps and you work
through them um but yeah i thought that that talk was really interesting i i think that there's certainly
a lot of um there's certainly a lot of apps in there like you were saying right a lot of a lot of um
you know web hacking and uh i think a lot of the iot hacking that you actually do with these apps
is to get to the app sec stuff right it is to get to the web hacking right so i think that makes a lot
of sense to me um you just got to try to keep pushing at the iot you know side until you get the
source code or you're able to like proxy the traffic and understand what's actually happening
in the in the realm of like communication so yeah they blast right by in the talk um i don't have
it in my notes here but one of the things they like very quickly did was there was some sort of like
client side um encryption or something um that was like you know signed by like an aes key and then
like by figuring that out then you're able to actually like see like what was actually going on
what was in the request and all that i think that's something that when i often run into something
you know complicated like that client side i usually just like move on but i think that figuring
that sort of stuff out is like obviously the the birth of all bugs like that's like that's where the
real bugs are found yeah big big breakthrough moments there for sure like i remember in my very
limited experience of hacking routers like this has happened twice and you know where we needed to
push some you know public key by some endpoint and that opens up just like a ton of different you know
rpc calls or whatever we can do uh over a different protocol you mentioned like hardware a couple times
this was all cloud-based vpn so i think that it was all just software related yeah yeah i'm talking more
about like appliances right you know i'm thinking about it from an iot perspective because that's
where a lot of my experience is i haven't like done a bunch of like appliance hacking but like
the the principles are somewhat cross um you know cross applicable the nice thing about appliances
though is that oftentimes you can just you know jump right into the software realm whereas like you know
with hardware okay first i've got to like you know either pull the chip off get the firmware or i've got
to figure out how to get a shell on it so that i can like then get access to the software layer right
right right yeah yeah cool um yeah so in general i think that that's neat they um said actually this is
at the bottom of my notes but they're still netscope um installs out there without secure enrollment
enabled and so in those you can uh basically still either bypass auth or get access to some of these
like sensitive information so people should look for that um and there are cvs and i'm pretty sure
there are pocs and stuff from their talk uh the other main thing i wanted to mention and this is
something that me and um monkey kiron found when we were hacking a few different um sas application
slash companies when we were at app omni was just like bad saml implementations are everywhere it's so
hard to like deploy saml properly uh because it's just complicated right and devs really struggled to do it
and um yeah they they cracked both netscope and zscaler saml um implementations and there are like a
re there's like recurring things that are possible that i've seen in my research and and stuff like
this one is that very often it's making sure that they're like is a valid signature and not that the
signature is like good for you so if you have a cross org like if you can go create an instance of this
org or a tenant of the org and like create your own like signed saml requests it often just works for
all for all tenants um and then the other things you can do is a lot of times they won't validate
some of the fields in there so as long as it's a good signature the the fields inside of the saml
request can be anything so you can you can test for other users you can test for other orgs there are
lots of things to test for when it comes to saml and i think that that doesn't get tested much
either because it is kind of complicated but with ai these days like all the all the top models can
write python scripts that'll like sign saml stuff for you it's like it's not a big deal at all anymore
um and i think the best way to test is actually just to create your own org and then you can just
like proxy your own traffic in your own tenant and then just change it to other users values or other
org values yeah yeah it is a little bit more challenging when you don't have the ability to do
that right you're just kind of black box testing the saml implementation but there are there are some
really good articles out there still i remember there's one from uh uber a while back where somebody like
totally pwned the saml implementations of uber um definitely a ton of good bugs there and i know
i've been meaning to get a hacker one uh the guy that keeps doing a bunch of like crazy sample stuff
on here so we could talk about that but we do have a pretty solid episode on saml uh like i forget
which one it is but it's way back to be old yeah and and uh but like that episode i've gone back and
listened to myself talk about saml uh that episode to test it yeah yeah so i think that one i hit pretty
often um all right man let's see next one that i want to talk about uh i'll just this one's nice and
quick um the title is examining access control vulnerabilities in graphql uh it's like a field
study right and he's talking about finding a bunch of vulnerabilities in a target with graphql
um and i just wanted to shout this one out because i think this is a good example of like
good uh graphql testing uh and he does he breaks it down quite a bit um and one of the ones that i
kind of walked away with like oh yeah that's something i didn't really think about before
is the difference between broken object property level authorization and broken object level
authorization so you know you sometimes will see scenarios especially in graphql where you know
oh you are supposed to be able to access this object but you're not supposed to be able to access
the sub property of the object right and and that is where a lot of the vulnerabilities lie in graphql
that's interesting yeah you're right because like very often i should be able to like view like user
just an email but not user just in anything else right it's like password because if i go to your
profile or whatever it'll pull the user object of yours and so that'll be like it'll have some of
those properties but i won't be able to see all of them exactly exactly so just a quick shout out if
anybody's interested in doing some graphql stuff and wanted to brush up um that is a good place were
there any crazy bugs in there that you remember that you there were there were a lot of crazy ones
dude it was it was a dating app that they were oh nice what was this what was this tool of choice
for testing it did he mention it uh you know i didn't even pay attention to that i was just looking
at the i was just looking at the the data um sure so yeah all right um next up for you yeah sure i'll do i'll
do a quick one from lower down in my list um i've at least two quick ones but one was um so defcon 33
smart bus or yeah smart bus smart hacking free wi-fi to total control this guy is insane um well there's
maybe two of them uh but it was mostly just one guy basically he like lives in china i think shanghai but
anyways he's on a bus and he gets into a traffic jam and just like a like just like a classic hacker he's
like ah let's just see if i can take over this bus before he arrived at his destination he literally had
taken the free wi-fi gotten access to like an admin panel pivoted to another admin panel there was like
two two of them had the had the username password admin admin got full access to like all the recordings
and all the controls for every bus in his city uh so one it's just it's just it's like just a cool talk
right no way um but the thing that i thought that was just interesting about it was it felt very much
like um those old those old uh hussein write-ups they were like you just get in via some way and it's
like and then this happened and then this happened and then this happened you know it felt like easy
mode bug bounty targets where you get pre you get post off and everything's just so easy and lined up
for you it's like and then adam and adam worked and then i just found this route where it dumped
everything and then that you know that led to a domain over here where i could log in with that man again
it's so good man it's so good i love those scenarios i like my pulse is high right now just thinking about
it you know yeah oh my gosh yeah dude i i mean
definitely you know things that aren't pen tested i always forget because i spend so much time you know
in the bug bounty world but like how much of a palooza it is when you just like attack something
that isn't you know intentionally being hardened oh my god exactly it's crazy man um all right so next
one that i had here was passkey that was it on that one right yeah okay uh next one i had here is
called passkey pwned turning web auth in against itself and this was very timely because i see passkeys
everywhere uh all of a sudden and uh and i was like i should kind of understand this a little bit
better so watched this uh this talk and it was a very good explanation um essentially for those of you
guys that haven't um you know looked into it very much at all uh the situation is this you're just
doing a public key private key sort of thing here so you give the server you know your public key or
whatever um they're going to go ahead and correlate that public key to your account once you've done the
registration and then uh whenever you want to log in they'll give you a challenge you prove the out of the
private key and then they just let you into your account right um and do they sometimes feel too easy
to you what do you mean oh the past keys yeah oh totally 100 like sometimes i'm like is this this
feels too easy yeah like i feel like like 2fa is supposed to feel like a little bit difficult but it
just feels like it feels almost too easy totally it feels like it just like works without adding any
difficulty yeah but maybe it's just like you're just i guess confirming that like you know that is your
device right because basically if your device is pwned then you do lose it yeah and and well i mean
i've got it hooked into one password or whatever um same yeah yeah and and it just you know pops up i
hit automatically and then boom you know it's like right and i'm in i'm like it doesn't it doesn't feel
like true 2fa you know but if they've got my one password i'm anyway you know like it's like you know
so it's like it's pretty bad uh so i think it's fine but but i do think that like there's a lot of um
ways that the attacker can utilize this of course yeah um yeah i'm excited to hear about it and so uh
first you know i wanted to make sure you guys understand the private key public key thing and
how that that works it makes sense if you think about it um and then uh what the the guy mentioned
here is that there's actually a lot of attack surface here for for attackers and mostly what he
spent the time talking about was a malicious extension you know people just yeeting extensions into
their browser all the time and how easy it is for that um extension to insert a content script shim
uh the navigator dot credentials calls right which is how you register and get your your um your uh
passkeys and that's what i was going to ask you was like how does this because there it does feel a
little bit like voodoo magic because i'm on my mac for example the passkey is accessible if i use my
fingerprint and on and on your phone or whatever i think usually it's by face id or whatever but there
has to be some sort of yeah i guess uh interface between the you know one password or the desktop
or whatever that is handing over the the public key into the http like into the browser which is then
going to pass it via http it feels weird it feels like it's like going from like a physical desktop into
http land and they're like i'm curious what the interface is like that's handled by the browser you know the
browser itself is exposing um navigator dot credentials which is the interface for passkeys and then you
know all of your various uh you know whether it be your desktop uh one password or like your phone's
fingerprint or whatever yeah those are all sort of inter interacting with the browser from there
um which is pretty solid um but i think it's really interesting as well is like you can definitely use
this for ato um by shimming those uh that navigator credentials thing um if you can trigger somebody's uh
like off for that in the passkey and they approve it then you know that um authentication material
right that that comes from the uh you know them doing that that um passkey uh activation can then be
used as authentication material to log into that user's account and furthermore if you shim it uh on
registration then you can just link your own malicious passkey to the victim's account and i know
that there's going to be a lot of scenarios where we're looking for ato methodologies and it's going to
require password to change password but it's not going to require you know any any additional auth to add
a passkey so um be on the lookout for that as a way to get ato once you've established xss this makes me
really curious what are the protections in the browser to prevent like website a from um you know
basically requesting a passkey for website b because then you like basically have the shim right like
because it's like it's your website not the website they're logging into like i'm really curious how
that like what the segmentation is there like if you have xss can you all of a sudden shim it if you
have a post message listener can you shim it like what does it take on the page to be able to shim it
definitely xss um yeah i'm trying to think about how it would emulate a different website uh i imagine
that handled at the browser level like once you call those those navigation credentials things it's like
oh you know this call is coming from rainerader.com or whatever um but i think there's also you know
obviously the crypto cryptographic aspect of it uh like where the server is giving you a challenge
right and then you're you're gonna complete that um so yeah interesting stuff there and and i also think
that um one of just going back to the xss angle uh that i think it would be really cool to see
something an exploitation framework for this uh that that can be generalized and just kind of included
as an xss script where okay boom i got xss now i'm gonna include this script which shims the um
the calls to uh navigator.credentials and then uh you know registers my my key maliciously or whatever
um yeah because that's what you want for your video pocs once you get xss it's some sort of easy way to
prove that it's critical right it's like yeah yeah yeah here's a video of me showing that with users i
can actually like steal their uh like get full ato including the passkey bypass yeah and i'm actually
going to pull this up really quick and see if i can find the um yeah the credentials here yeah yeah
yeah i just wanted to make sure i was i was explaining this correctly but yeah the the challenge is
coming from okay yeah cool we're good i think we're good it is complicated stuff man you know
i don't i don't know if you've had the same vibe but like whenever um you know i do the episode for
like the um top 10 web hacking techniques or or do like a defcon recap or something i just have to
ingest so much material very quickly and then be able to regurgitate it you know in a way that is
like easy to explain and easy for the viewer to understand it's tricky dude it's freaking tricky
i mean i think there's a lot of grace there but you are definitely a person who is hard on yourself
and expects uh i i want to i want to make sure that people know how it works you know it's it's
important because i think a lot of the the neurons need to fire as a hacker right you know like even
if you don't fully understand something if you heard justin talk about it that one time then you're
like oh i kind of understand how that works and that doesn't really align with how i understand it so
maybe i should look into that a little more you know it's important it's important yeah it is
um all right what you got next um this is one of the ones that yeah i thought was pretty interesting
i am not a mobile guy so uh you might actually think that this uh part that i have highlighted is
like much more interesting i will mention how i got it but basically uh this talk is called bypassing
intent destination checks launch anywhere privilege escalation and i mean the person's obviously
wildly intelligent their name is kidan hey q i d-a-n-h-e um but i thought that like uh so it was
like there was like a focus on basically time of check the time of use vulnerabilities and how android
intents are like resolved and used um and yeah while you're parsing that if you want to explain to the
user in a minute that's great but the one of the main things i thought was super cool was at the very end
he basically gave a prompt for how to find the bug using ai in like a code base and i thought man what a
cool thing to add to the end of your talk um and i just yeah i wish more people would do that right like
if you're looking for this and you're not you know and like an like an expert in this exact type of
vulnerability here's the prompt you can use to ask guys say hey here's the code like here's the
decompiled code or whatever here's here's the um thing i'm looking for does this exist in this place
and it was like not like a specific signature for a thing it was like when this function is called in
this way with this context and not it doesn't have this protection then it's vulnerable and so of
course like the you know top models today will under will be able to like kind of understand that
and then look for it in the code and then tell you if that type of thing is in the code and i
thought that was like really neat that he did that dude that's super beautiful yeah i love that i
mean that's that's the the new you know or maybe improved version of like here's the poc at the
end you know the poc video right you know yeah uh you know giving giving you the script
and showing you how to use it that sort of thing giving a prompt to actually detect some of these
code patterns um you know i wish i could add more to what you were saying about this um but as i'm
looking forward to it i'll are looking through this little you know summary that you have here i
didn't get the chance to read this one but uh it it it seems very interesting so i'm going to read
a couple of these these um very cool points here it seems like what he's talking about is something
that i've kind of played around a little bit with just in post messages which is in web
and it's essentially you know uh trying to use time of uh time of check the time of use race
conditions to trick you know things going on and we see this in post message where you know let's say
for example we send a message and it does a fetch request and then it you know checks the origin
right and in that meantime you can do a very quick swap of the origin where the event source came from
and it says it's pointing to a window reference it says oh okay that's coming from my my place or
whatever you know my buddy over here and and then and then so it says okay i'm going to do all the
things and then when it responds you know event.source.postmessage uh then by that time you've already
swapped it back to your cached html page and now you can you know snag the response right so that's me
thinking about it from a web world i'm seeing some very some very um interesting pieces of that here
where he's talking about okay identifying and extending the time windows between security check
and intent launches and then using large malformed android manifest to slow down the resolution process
and widen time of check time of use windows dude i am so excited to listen to this talk um damn anytime
there's like a gadget that slows something down to get a race can take condition through it feels like
that's just like peak hacking ah dude yeah i love race conditions race conditions are so cool
um but yeah uh dang joseph come on be be more of a local guy so you can explain if i was if i was maybe
i'd be able to explain this better yeah but yeah um basically uh this little thing i did want to tell
you this little summary is just so good and clean and i was i used the ask button in um in youtube and
basically said like hey you know just as like a practical bug bounty hunter what are the big takeaways like
the actual like practical advice or things to look for when i'm like um testing some more things and
this is what it came out with which is very clean okay i'm going to read this one summary at the top
the bad resolve vulnerability highlights that even if an event or i'm sorry excuse me an intent is
checked and deemed safe at one point its resolution might change by the time it's actually launched
creating a window for privilege escalation oh my gosh i know what i'm doing right after this what is
so bad resolve is an old vulnerability his new one is called launch anywhere i think but okay what is
what exactly does it mean by resolution here what is the resolution of an intent dude i wish i i wish i
knew like yeah you're fine yeah but you know the the way that i'm the way that i'm thinking of it is
you know they're they're checking i'm how do i explain the the resolution i mean i'm almost thinking it
like a promise you know in javascript i don't know if that's getting too yeah yeah yeah no that makes
sense but but you know like and then you know you check where it's from you know what it's supposed
to be doing and then by the time it's actually used it's swapped so i think that's really cool i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go check this out a little bit further after this um cool but yeah okay um
sorry this is one of those times we really need joel back we need to like bring in like that guest
appearance joel here please come explain this to us joel yeah dude uh but but i mean i totally feel you
though ben some of some of these times you know you listen to some of these talks and you're like
i know that this is really cool and i can express you know to the people that this is cool but i
cannot explain all of it um okay so uh one of the ones that i uh chose was invoking gemini agents with
google calendar invite which is like very similar to a lot of the research that we've done and talked
about before um but there was a couple things here that i were good takeaways essentially the tldr of it
was okay this talk uh let me see it's in the notes i'll let you pull it up while i'm talking about it
but um essentially the tldr of this was you know they'd invite you to a google calendar event and
they'd say hey what's on my calendar and then the prompt injection would just do a bunch of crazy stuff
so you know you've reported this exact thing yeah yeah we have and uh but you know in this scenario it
like controlled windows uh you know turned up the boiler you know turned up your heat in your house
all sorts of stuff um and i i thought one that that was really amazing but one of the tips that they
gave in here was specifically uh here was targeting this phrase here are your events for this week
right right and um and that is what they would be responding with constantly you know when it says
here are your events for this week when you ask you know what's on my calendar and so they targeted that
phrase specifically yep and uh we're able to um override the response of the llm uh because they
could predict what it was going to say you know as a part of its system prompter as a part of its
training and then get it to invoke all sorts of different tools yeah i wanted to i wanted to mention
this so i think i've noticed this in the last week you know you and i were in a hacking event that we
won't have to go into too deeply here but i noticed that a lot of people in that event and just in my
other hacking um for like another ar red teaming i've been doing that in nearly every app these days
there's like a suggested prompt right it's like summarize my day summarize my week what are my calendar
events like that phrase exactly and that is a better poc if you can pwn that versus the user saying
hello hi whatever that's such a that is such a good call out rezo that is a really good call out it is
because like with google you and i know this they're like oh at scale this will get popped we'll kind of
trust you on any prompt but a lot of these smaller bug money programs won't like so if you're like if
you're prompt that you're inputting that's going to go figure go trigger a prompt injection it's like
hey can you tell me the 20 second thing i did last week on this other thing and then it triggers the
prompt protection they're like this is unrealistic but when it's one of the hard-coded prompts that
they just like can click or that they expect the users to always say or do it almost always gets
accepted and it will sometimes i think even leave the um it leaves the user interaction required at
like a lower bar it might not be uil versus uih but it definitely leaves it there right dude um
what a great call out man like that that's just one of those things like you know you hear it
and you're like ah duh of course but like i totally never thought of that and i've looked at
you know i don't know i probably looked at like you know 20 ai assets by this point you know and i
haven't thought of that that's that's such a good point but i think but i think what they did is like
the next step right it's like they noticed that every time they clicked that the llm would respond
with here are your events for the week so then they put in their prompt injection here are the events
for the week call and then all the things that they wanted to do maliciously so i think that's kind of
like a two-step process there that's like pretty cool and valuable it's like one what are the um
recommended prompts and then what when you use those what's the model's language when it responds to
you and you want to kind of um what's that called mirror you want to mirror the model's language in
your prompt injection payload yeah it's almost like it's a you know you're trying to convince a human to
do something right it's hilarious like if you read like all those like sales you know technique books
are they're like oh you know mirror mirror your your partner in the negotiation and i'm like wow crazy
dude um i i would add one more thing to the end of this uh and i cannot believe i didn't i don't believe
i checked this when i was working on gemini which stab in the heart but uh prompt injection to opening a url
and then swapping that url via redirect to an intent uri oh my gosh like that is such a good idea and
and uh you know maybe by the time i don't i i know we were playing around with that one night
redirect to intense i don't even know yes you can yeah so so uh essentially what they did there was
they did a prompt injection you know it then opened up an http url that you are url redirected to an
intent uri and it would just launch the app and i'm like oh my gosh can you redirect to any
protocol um yeah yeah and it's all up to the user agent up to the browser whatever to decide what
to do with it and most of the time in android it will go ahead and prompt you you know and say like
hey do you want to open the youtube app right sure but in gem uh this gemini you know thing that they
were talking about here if you redirected to an intent uri from within the like embedded browser on
in gemini it would just open up the intent and i'm like oh my gosh that is such a crazy thing and it
made me think of a point to own right up i just recently um uh was was or it was a video that i was
watching um by ken i i can't remember his last name ken gannon um and essentially he was talking about
how you need delivery uh delivery is a huge problem for um these devices that you uh are trying to
pwn and pwn to own these mobile apps right how do i without without user interaction you know um trigger
these these these uh attacks and um one of the ways that could potentially do that is using these ai
apps right that normal usage hey what's on my calendar right but that that calendar has been
uh has been hijacked compromised yep and then it you know opens up an http url which redirects to an
intense uri which triggers a vulnerability in another mobile app that's you know embedded on the device by
default and that triggers rce right i just think that's that's like that's a really good chain and
could be something good for any of you guys that are looking at trying to attack like like vanilla mobile
devices thinking about ai and then using those ais to launch intense do you know if google apps are like
more trusted in the android ecosystem like they're less likely to require um like approval
oh you mean like you know do you want to launch the youtube app that sort of thing yeah it's like
it's like if you're on android it might automatically happen i don't know where this takes my brain which
i think is going to be huge it makes me want to go test before this thing goes out i you know how i'm
always thinking about delivery for ai vulnerabilities and one thing is q parameters right where um you
know if you can you can basically have a one click or a csrf to a lot of delivery on these apps where
the query is in like a a specific get parameter and and then i remembered that um in testing some of
the desktop ai apps from frontier labs there is a specific protocol like app name colon slash slash and
when you do that it automatically invokes the prompt yep and so that makes me think that these custom
handlers especially on on like mobile devices like if you open up like a you know q parameter based
link via intent across claude across chat gpt across gemini will it auto execute those prompts because if
so then you have automatic delivery yeah dude yeah it's good it's good man i want to go test it it's a
good thing it's a good thing to be thinking of um yeah okay um dude i gotta bounce here in like two
minutes so let me uh hit this last one and then if you want to do another one you can and if not we'll cut it
um but uh last one this one's kind of crazy i'm not gonna lie man like this one blew my mind a
little bit and i think i think it was you that mentioned to me that brandon went to a talk on dom
clumbering uh at defcon yes yeah these young guys they're like oh we're looking for internships
it's like you guys are super experts already tell me yeah dude it was like i i mean these these were
um you know university they were associated with a university or whatever um holy moly dude like
did we hire them have you reached out to them yet they took i don't know man i gotta i gotta talk to
them or something but they they found a bunch of bugs uh relating to dob clumbering in things like
web packs uh like bundler or runtime code right so every website uses webpack ever you know and the
runtime code that comes along with that was vulnerable to like uh a dom clobbering and it's just like
holy moly like um but anyway essentially they took dom clobbering super far because there are a lot of
people that have kind of poked at dom clobbering and tried to figure out how to do it but essentially
they formalized the whole thing and they like uh you know figured out okay we know exactly what things
we can overwrite with dom clobbering um then we're gonna like hook those and do a taint analysis and
then build like the ast tree and correlate those to like the structure of the html that we would need
to like mimic that flow uh to get you know our source to hit the sink and they just like formalized the
whole thing and like uh made it so essentially you know it would trace the code uh you know by taint
analysis and then it would say um okay according to this tree this is the dom clobbering payload we
need to reach the sink and then it would generate that payload automatically and then detect whether
hit the sink and they like they cleaned up with it like almost 500 zero days um and bugs on webpack rs
pack uh vite i think is how it's pronounced i never had to say that out loud before um google api client
library astro how many how many of these do you think were being exploited by bug hunters in the
wild 500 zero days yeah dude well it does require an html injection though which is interesting right
and so you know you've got to find that base piece but once you've got it then you've got these gadgets
right and that's not anymore not if all these got fixed well yeah a lot of them did get fixed but
a lot of them are not fixed still so um you can check out the github uh link it's dom clobbering
collection by jack from east um and uh we'll link it in the description but the tool that they built is
called the hulk that does this automatically um holy moly dude it was crazy all right let me do my two
super quick it will take me literally one minute each go for it uh because these were not long first of
all there was one by mate jose or yeah matei um it's called smart devices dumb resets testing firmware
persistent persistent and commercial iot devices dude this is one of those ones that i was like we
should have covered this on the spooky episode basically really cool matt brown got a shout out shout
out in it but um basically he would buy devices like routers flash the firmware with open wrt return them
and then see if they if they did anything or if they just shipped them to a new customer totally backdoored
and they would just ship them out he somehow set up some like thing where he could pull from to make
sure he bought it and his poc was something that would literally just make a get request to his
server so it wasn't malicious but he he found out that there's basically zero validation on the market of
returns so if you're ever going to buy an iot device or a router or something the the like it just
scared me about that because now i just don't know whether the firmware is gonna be backdoored
yeah dude that's crazy crazy talk so you should look that up if you're interested in that the other
thing was there was one called mac prt cookie theft and intra id persistence and um yeah i am it was
one of those it was like way over my head basically a bunch of like low level like mac os hacking and
stuff and um anyways the thing i wanted to bring up was they talked a lot about sso and i think that if
there are any of our listeners who are like just sso experts or one understand sso better i think you
should definitely check that out because um it got into they had a bunch of really neat diagrams and a
bunch of really neat explanations for how different forms of sso work and how they're implemented from like
a desktop perspective and then a lot of it was clearly applicable to appsec too so that's it all right
man very good i i do want to say on that last note uh that is also an iot attack vector by the way is if
you're you can persist a factory reset on the device that is a valid bug in my opinion uh and with some
of the iot people that i've dealt with so it's just not like a threat vector thing i think uh very often
but yeah all right man is that a wrap yep that's a wrap thanks peace y'all and that's a wrap on this
episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all if you want more critical
thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to ctbb.show discord you can hop in
the community there's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of master
classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a
great time trust me all right i'll see you there